You know,
I think that allowing marijuana to become legal should not have allowed.
The type of taxation that's been allowed in California.
Colorado was at one point in time was 39% yeah.
What does it in California,
I don't know,
but it's high enough that I seen an owl.
So we go from about $150 to 320 bucks.
I think that's terrible,
but I would like it if all that money went to a good purpose,
but we know it's not.
Yeah,
that's
right.
You're counting shit.
You know what I'm saying?
It,
it never lands where it should.
It never does what it's supposed to do.
Right.
That's what I'm,
that's,
that's what I'm getting to it.
That's why I say it went to Syria.
When I say,
you know,
I don't want to be that guy,
but usually I don't go back for bribery just because you're just like,
God fucking damn.
Like why isn't good happening in the immediate cause so much money is pushed
into the immediate,
well,
if we does become legal worldwide,
it's in Thai.
I mean countrywide.
It's entirely possible that it's going to stimulate economies and a lot of very
poor places.
It's going to have some real positive benefit.
I agree,
but,
but what,
what I'm saying about capitalism is why are we not ensuring that the people who
have suffered since 1937 have a fair shot?
Right.
We've allowed so many laws to come in with marijuana legalization that it does
not allow for the spa businessman to have the type of ingenuity is set up that
are small liquor store had at the end of prohibition or bar.
You know,
Jamie was telling me that in Ohio they were setting it up so they were trying to
make it legal,
but only two guys can grow it to enormous corporations.
That was the bill,
right?
Is that how it worked,
Jamie?
I believe it might've been four or something like it wasn't a lot.
Some small amount of people.
They were the only ones who could grow it in.
I'm saying Bro,
like that we know.
We know that's fucked up.
That's so crazy that he wouldn't even ask for them.
We notice fucked up when it should just be,
you are allowed to grow it with a,
with $100 state,
federal tax,
state tax stamp,
you gotta stay tax,
they have 100 bucks,
you can grow up to three acres with marijuana.
Bam.
Love it,
love it.
Perfect.
Lovely.
Do Your Shit.
And then the growers have to buy from you.
So if a farmer wants to make a collective with,
for the farmers,
they're making that collective,
but we shouldn't be able to,
to,
to allow that type of domination because essentially then you're just giving
people,
you know,
monopolies of sorts.
You know,
so it's,
it's like I just,
I don't trust us to,
to be on our shit enough with the people we leave in charge.
Right.
Well it also,
it wouldn't make sense in any other relationship.
And then the of the relationship we're,
all someone is saying is if I let you sell something,
you give me a certain percentage because you're basically saying that all of
the,
the frameworks of our government and the city's roads that you drive on and all
that stuff takes money to maintain.
So we're just going to take a little piece now.
They'd taken 39% yeah,
that's so much should.
But if that 39% went all to public schools and paying teachers money and paying
cops and paying firemen and community centers,
but beyond just pain,
good son of a former cop,
cousin of car cops,
policemen should be from areas that they're policing or areas like those.
They should be offered no interest loans to live at.
And around those communities,
teachers should be also,
and the fire department,
they should almost hold a special place because of the nobility of those jobs
and how important they are.
We all should do stuff like tax freeze is once you retire,
whatever your taxes are,
once you retire at 65 years old,
we should knock baby 10 20% off.
And that's what you pay until you die.
You know what I mean?
We should do everything we can to make the the class of people you're saying
about affluence possible and we're not doing it like that's,
I guess that's the only button I'm pushing when I seen,
cause I'm a very optimistic person,
but my pessimism,
my pessimism comes more from the lack of what I seen us be willing to do to make
sure that each one another treated fairly then I have seen for.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?